welcome back to the lobby
I'm Daniel Dwyer and I'm joined by
Smorgasburg ins Morgan Board of a bunch
of critic review critic people that's
what your says on your business cards
when people recommend the s it says
review critics Minh when people
recommend the course of action to buy a
flight stick I have to show up and say
don't ya don't care how good the game is
Jeff Carson from Johnny ball oh right
see I was just doing that but yeah now I
can make it a fail yeah yeah absolutely
lock it in okay I'm actually really six
you might wanna clean your hand oh I was
thinking that as I'm seeing your hand
I've been really sick Oh Kevin found
hard reviews that are for gave spot yeah
Chris waters hey Danny I do buddy and
you're a gamer decided to dump review
scores today but one of my favorite
things about review scores is that
sometimes games get ones out of tens on
GameSpot this has happened four times
and it happened to game for the fourth
time didn't they technically just
replace their review score with a three
points game it's just a three point
scale is it really that's like a yes
yeah no no there's a fourth the fourth
one is they don't put one of those
stickers on it sometimes they just don't
give it an emblem okay yeah looks like a
six-point scale sure or a 5a thing yeah
see you folks have given some of these
ones before we talked about the ones I
want to talk about the zeros so
sometimes there are games that
accidentally get zero Chris I believe
you did this
oh yeah man like I forgot to post put
the review score in the drop down before
I posted the review four nights contract
yeah and then all of a sudden the next
morning it's popping up on like what all
these different sites that just pull our
scores to post and I'm looking at
comments and people are just baffled
they're like wow GameSpot is off it I
mean the game functions doesn't it
what the hell sure it functions six
point five out of ten very good nights
contract functionally that's you know
that's the word that goes onto that
right how do you accidentally coworkers
yeah no I can I couldn't tell you what
the game was but yeah it's if you don't
enter anything in the system and hit
publish it would come up as a zero great
um and yeah I had a similar situation
where then you know there were people on
some message board somewhere arguing
about like it's better than a zero
surely it's but she'd do that by
accident from signing me funny I've
never signed up for a temporary account
for all those message boards just to be
like no guys he just go back game
the publishers pressure to change blah
that's what happened they bought that
6.5 yo that's dude that's Ryan 4-0 edit
that's right yeah that's what happens at
the first year at a ten ever given big
rigs over the road racing one down in
games sorry one at a ten it's gone down
in the GameSpot history November that I
went on 2003 one of the best reviews
ever on site it's uh so big rigs was uh
for a while there when we when we ran
out of things to give to Alex we would
go to Walmart and just buy stuff off the
shelves okay
and there were a lot of things that just
got weird distribution at a Walmart and
nowhere else and this was such a game
well I truck and really reversed it's
basically broken like it's basically not
a game
so you know you could make a case that
this is a zero if if one were to have a
this isn't a game ranking on your game
review scale this would probably be the
one to get it Alex unsurprisingly over
the years has been the primary advocate
for let me give something a zero because
you don't got you guys don't give zero
as a diamond we go we we also only go
down to one Wow
sort of like you know if there's a game
that we're gonna try to give a zero to
ads are we're just we're not gonna be
covering it anyway I just realized
there's actually a copy of it behind me
so I'm gonna go get that oh let's see if
there's any sick bucks quotes on it hi
Alex did he did like a speedrun or so or
whatever amounts to a speedrun of this
yeah off read awesome games done quick
that awesome Fiesta every year what
people do like really six yeah you need
a glitch exhibition have the infinite
speed in Reverse situation and then also
yes speed ran the game your winner
indeed yeah so and then Alex actually I
think went on to interview the person
behind this over at game mail publish
over say yeah well game mill I don't
think exists Keller stone yes tower
stone game mill stellar they made
something since then right I want to say
that they made something after that
remember what they but there was I think
the the guy that one of the guys that
was attached to big rigs had something
that
in early access that went sideways oh I
could be remembering so yeah exactly
that that awful Daisy type again yes I
want to say that a lot of negative kind
of want to say that is in fact the game
yeah right I could be making that not
this one
get ready for some break jamming CB
talking convoy rolling action across
America I mean it's technically I think
the game has breaks I don't think it has
any CDs in it that's a shame
does it have cost you can run off the
road look at the front you probably dry
it has no shine racing anything like
it's just an environment that is like a
it's like a battlefield hard it's barely
yeah it's barely a proof of concept
battlefield hardline in stores market no
it's speaking of that it matically it's
also actually relatively close to our
second one out of ten which was last
year right to hell retribution yeah
another break jamming CV talk and
rolling across America but that was a
motorcycle game yeah yeah that game was
a real piece of hot rod I never played
this it's real bad
it's real bad but you know like what
what is going on oh my goodness a face
full of exhaust that's what happens you
can't afford to look at this like this
is still a game it's messed up it's you
know like these are those are cutscenes
and obviously you know the actions gonna
not look as good but look at that he
kicked that guy off that bike like roll
rush whoa make a noise that I can do
QuickTime events I mean come on
yeah and look at that guy is that guy
worth of 1.0 I think that the reviewers
may be a little harsh if you're 1.5 what
are you more 1/5 a to oh maybe I'll get
a punch that dude hey I love QuickTime
events on PC that's why I'm so psyched
up if you are and wide bombing at us
this guy's a tough talk down the drywall
talk what do you like are the girls to
get it on with the lady right there
though oh oh right oh wait are they just
heavy petting zoo point five heavy free
pot of hot coffee is that the giant
hands
Jack you got crazy all they say is giant
hands yeah
began motorcycles look at this that's a
right that same year well we got our
third one out of ten same slot tasted
the nectar upset caving games ones right
let's go I think
was like it would but it wasn't the same
week it was like a within the same about
was it I don't even remember it was so I
barely remember like I remember ride to
hell but I never played it it's the only
like it's the only one we've ever given
that I haven't played but you have
played air control yeah I reviewed air
can I did one of those ones was mine
yeah that that game is actually a big
rigs realm okay type thing oh this is a
well this is the worst this was made in
unity and it has all this like
placeholder unity stuff in it like this
disc it's just absolute garbage
ridiculous some dude played around in
unity and had the balls to charge people
money for it do you know what does it
mean next yeah I remember this with this
game was attempting to be
tongue-in-cheek and like no self-aware
but a kind of a work of art kind of see
I I reject that I think this is the
Birdemic of games in the sense that I
think now we think well it's charming
and was trying to be self effacing
but I don't actually believe that was
audience yeah no I don't yeah I hold to
know what the intent was the lock cursor
thing I could not stop laughing at the
entire time I was playing as blocks of
lime jell-o and then and then this
clearly downloaded from the unit or
environment um a lot of people looked
into this and realize that a lot of this
stuff was just yeah stolen great mom
sound effects stolen they used some
Airlines uh like voiceover thing right I
forget I forget exactly which airline
United or something like that I just
stole that straight out there in a way
unites just giving them what was even
your role are you the stewardess if
you're whatever sometimes you fight
terrorists some there's one mode where
you are a flight attendant yep this game
reminds me of soda drinker Pro except so
dry throw is an actual work of art yep
so that is self-aware but this is really
a zero I mean it's hard to compare
something like this that's just clearly
look at busted Lee not that's so taken
from Google Images it's not even enough
that's why I'm like if you look at this
and you look at big rigs like honestly
really this is a ride pal is like a game
of the Year contender compared to that
stuff all right well maybe you'll find
issue with our latest one out of 10 up
on the site today ravenscry what's wave
this ravenscry have a level where it
transports you to the future and you are
serving drinks on a plane yes
Wow you play a lot longer than I then
III no I don't think so
it is however um awful beyond measure
I didn't review this but I've been
playing it all day and I really want
that time back okay I really really want
to polish this now look at the got
dialogue choices it's not like a lock
cursor thing everywhere on the [ __ ]
screen I'm gonna do some texture there
is textures I am gonna say I have got a
lot of patience for jank RPGs right
I mean I've reviewed so many of them I
really like the Risen series for example
what risen is is this
I even like two worlds too by the same
developer like two worlds one was
trashed but I kinda like two worlds do
they play did some stuff that they did
some stuff now this is now there's
clearly some heart and some effort I
think this looks like a video game just
so bad you asked me to like look away
for a while I turn my head over here and
then like quickly look at the screen
turn away be like no you're playing
sanskrit over there yeah so but this is
just that the whole first thing in
general that you do like the spit it's
like what's the story I don't know
suddenly I'm just like I'm behind the
wheel of a ship and I'm moving around
and then it's called in media res kinam
thank you Chris you're for your
storytelling prowess but but it's it's
just this way I mean it's buggy first of
all you can't finish this game because
the story crashes because it goes on
forever
this is an epic pirate tale like it
crashes at one point the story and
nobody can can finish it which is which
is one big thing that I write but I ran
into like all sorts of things but I was
what at least I was laughing like a lot
of the stuff the voice acting is just so
dead boy so I could combat is hysterical
well it has kind of voice acting every
so often
yeah like ice combats awful usual to to
number one number two now it's still
more realistic than assassin's creed
combat you're like oh wait my 20 Herod's
brought to life look at this
yeah what is it like suddenly like the
original risen light looks like a work
of art with its combat compared to
something like this and it's just and
it's and this is the game like
everything is just executed so poorly
that it's I don't know a bus it's really
offensive would you rather play this
line executed as it is so so poorly done
to the point that it makes you laugh or
executed like a little more competently
that nothing is like super leering Li
wrong but it's just dull as dull can't
see you're you're you're hitting on a
thing that I always talk about which is
I'd rather play something that's bad
than boring yep um yeah like air control
totally I'd rather give once and sixes
man yeah the five is the hardest thing
to write I swear to God like the five is
the hardest thing ever to write at least
with a one you can have fun with it but
this isn't even fun in that air control
way like where you could just point and
laugh like this is like you know
somebody was trying and then you just
feel sad great ravenscry review on
GameSpot calm you know it's gonna get a
lot more views than it would have got it
too so that's something too happy about
probably that's why they give a man
exactly we're in the publisher bought
that yeah ravenscry right up there with
with game mail on lining our pockets I
wonder if that's the actual copy of big
rigs or if you guys went out and bought
another one at some point which is
scarier to consider floating in it
actually in there is it staying the
galaxy's war library yeah I think Alex
Isaiah the guy when I started he
actually made me play big rigs as part
of like some initiation ceremony thing
dark yeah yeah it was it was the
roughest day of my life cause I made him
play big rigs so well they go whenever
that he would pass it on whatever
exactly when we filled out that new
position and we'll just have to get them
to play all of these pieces of hot
garbage yeah thank you very much for
coming on and talking about terrible
video games what you guys going on on
giantbomb on your side of the office as
well there's I believe there's a quick
look ravenscry up great if you want to
see Vinny and Alex plan that thing I
think I want to say they played that
just to be making that up still forcing
out X play crap game
course yeah no this is this is how it
goes forever and ever for all time until
he succumbs until he can make it stop
anytime he wants to tap out he just has
to give up uh the podcast just went up
um so yeah you know listen be yelling
about The Legend of Zelda this week I
think it's cool that's what you're
yelling bad this week every week somehow
you know majora is coming out there's a
lot to say hmm
um and yeah and then premium a members
there's that two episode of dancers oh
yeah on the website life and dancers
with Dan and Danny the advice podcast
that is burning up the charts yeah I
never realized how when you say it out
you say that what just sounds like
dancing I was the first I hadn't even
known literally just now great which is
why people keep sending questions to the
wrong email address which is owned by
someone else who must be wondering what
the [ __ ] is going on well they get it
they get what they deserve on that look
forth Kevin what do you got in the works
this week oh god it's a slow week uh
orderers next week like cool so are we
playing that soon yeah hopefully I'll
homeworld soon to start playing oh yeah
it's kind of dead
I want to bet you mr. waters I I start
playing game yesterday called sunless
sea oh yeah uh which is this a naval
exploration game set in this kind of
fallen London dystopian steampunky
arcane universe type thing that's that's
what actual London is like now yeah it's
uh very it's challenging its a
permadeath it's got a lot of stories
like a lot of the world building is
text-based and then you have all these
weird commodities you pick up in
exchange like you can develop you can
have get secrets and then you could
trade them to upgrade this stat or trade
it this port or selling secrets go to
the hell port and they will like bail up
your terror level but they're also gonna
give you like tales of despair which you
can sell at other port roguelike as well
it's fascinating
roguelike like road like one of those
things I'm really intrigued by it I'm
trying to figure out a good way for us
to showcase it kind of a long-form
experience um but the way you're kind of
like exchanging stories and stuff like
that almost sounds like velvet sundown
yep
speaking of one out of tens and we
review this and out of ten more like we
reviewed velvet sundae know
oh no we should get on that 15 out of 10
make it got done and that's it for this
week yeah a new episode of the point
going up on Friday I want to remind
people that we have a giveaway all you
folks in the chat you can win the tiny
RL on the screen right now poink and
tiny well calm /gs evolve it's copy of
the game and the headphones do people
have to put in what platform they want
that on yeah alright let us know a
platform PC Xbox one ps4 when you fill
in that form yeah which of the 20
different versions do they get yeah they
buy to know they got the we're actually
just giving them a DLC pack that's got
unlock in two months time great and a
pair friends yeah right
Oh gravity bike gravity games bike
Street vert dirt you mean yeah whoa
street furniture for all three types of
property by streets verts dirts this
wasn't the one at a ten I know this is
like a one point four there was
something that we used to do on some of
these yeah this is this is be playing it
I feel sorry I still have it stop the
shirt no ravenscry um and this game
seemingly got dumped at Costco Midway
was putting it out and then suddenly my
inquiries for review code um and my
increase for review code started going
unanswered and then I found a copy just
sitting out at a Costco cool and bought
it and and played it and it's a it's a
mess
great uh yeah it's a fantastic mess
that's not the video I thought it was I
don't know what that was oh really well
we're gonna play that after the credits
so we'll make sure you stick around uh
yeah alright that's it
lobby for this week's Tuesday 2 p.m.
Pacific next week we've got a bunch of
people from bosses studios in and we're
gonna talk about other video games
alright hopefully the order included so
we will see you guys then and until then
adios have some video games
you
hello dear viewers and welcome to
GameSpot live it's time to play which is
more fun here we have Jeff Jeff has a
problem which is more fun this barely
playable xbox game or this empty
cardboard box
sounds like a toughy let's see what Jeff
does he's clearly thinking about it
eyeing both of these subjects very
closely hmm I don't know what you should
pick either do you come on Jeff what's
it going to be I think he's got it grab
it again
wait what's this the cardboard box
gravity games bike for the Xbox don't
play this game
you